il lui aura fallu 17 ans pour enfin agir
à l'âge de 30 ans l'actrice adèle haenel
dépose sa plainte contre le réalisateur
christophe ruggia il procédait toujours
de la même façon et se coller à moi
m'embrassait ai commencé à me caresser
elle s'était confiée au site mediapart
le 3 novembre dernier affirmant qu'elle
avait subi un vrai calvaire à
l'adolescence à l'âge de 13 ans alors
qu'elle tournait son premier film les
diables avec le réalisateur mais choqué
s'il fallait encore plus par le fait
qu'ils disent ce qui m'a découverte
parce qu'en fait il m'a surtout
détruites d'accord et qu'en fait si
christophe ruggia une emprise sur moi
c'est parce que moi le travail sur le
jeu le théâtre c'est quelque chose que
j'ai viscéralement encore elle décide de
parler lorsqu'elle apprend entre autres
qu'il va tourner un autre film avec des
adolescents après ces révélations
une enquête judiciaire a été ouverte le
réalisateur a été radié par la société
des réalisateurs de films
même s'il a démenti des faits
aujourd'hui adèle haenel réclament
réparation
samedi ils étaient près de 50000
apparaît à manifester contre le
harcèlement les violences sexuelles les
féminicides parmi les manifestantes
l'actrice sandrine bonnaire qui livre à
son tour un témoignage glaçant sur la
violence qu'elle a subie il ya 20 ans
par son ex conjoint
ce quelqu'un qui a pété les plombs
kima strangulée contre 1 contre un mur
j'ai essayé de me défendre j'ai levé les
bras j'ai jeu je suis tombé dans les
pommes
je me suis retrouvé deux mètres plus
loin avec le visage complètement de
travers avec la langue en lambeaux vous
savez comme du tissu qu'on découpe avec
800 cas c'est avec une ouverture ici
et
et je me suis réveillé j'ai craché plein
de morceaux dedans du sang opéré
d'urgence
elle est paralysée pendant un mois et
demi et porte plainte
la personne en question a pris deux ans
de sursis seulement avec une
condamnation financière importante je
trouve que de se montrer vulnérable
comme elle est comme elle l'a fait c'est
s'est aussi montré beaucoup de force
pour l'auteur pascal navarro ses
actrices parle aussi au nom des femmes
qui subissent en silence
elle comprend qu'elle a qu'elles peuvent
faire beaucoup dans cette source sur ce
thème là qu'elle peut aider beaucoup
d'autres femmes et c'est une des choses
sur lesquelles elle a beaucoup insisté
que de dire qu'elle avait les moyens et
qu'elle a eu les moyens de sa
reconstruction aussi la parole est
libérée le débat se fait dans l'espace
public
maintenant il faut légiférer en france
dit-elle ça va changer si les demandes
et les actions s'inscrivent dans des
lois parce que sinon on va recommencer
dans quelques années si l'on mesure pas
si on documentation légifère pas et si
on ne sanctionne pas et rien qui va
changer
si vous voulez changer une culture ben
il faut aller au fond des choses en 2019
115 femmes ont été tuées en france par
leur conjoint issia c'est beau de
légumes guise radio canada montréal